Brock pie might be the starting
quarterback for one of the best teams in
the NFL right now but he still lives a
pretty simple life he recently revealed
in an interview with NBC that he still
has a roommate it's one of the offensive
linemen on his team right now and they
both still split red and that's not all
instead of driving a super fancy car
like most quarterbacks would he still
drives a Toyota seoa think about it like
this he's still on his rookie deal and
he's only making $870,000 right now now
he's still making a lot more than most
23-year-olds but still with the level
he's playing at there's no doubt that
Brock is going to get paid really soon